and create a new standard you take
something that's not just a little bit
different but take something that's
really
really captures people's imagination
ever doubt the magic of software
notice that this scanner build whoa
there's so many dreams we've had about
the web that still aren't there
we've kept our marriage secret for over
a decade now we're a company that's
admired probably as much as any on the
planet and when we fall short we're
committed to do battle am I ready to
take my shirt off
well I think where they say we're ready
to do the slideshow that beam keeps
blinking so think but I think not so
maybe we'll move on yet again resistance
is futile
because in the world of technology too
often to have a leader who gets replaced
I feel very excited about where the
company is going and the fact that I'll
still have a few projects that I get to
push and put my mark on
I'll move from being a full-time
employee Microsoft working full-time at
the foundation